O, nos decidimos a prevenir la demencia,
y jamás nos pasará porque haremos todo correctamente y nunca vendrá por nosotros.
Yo intento buscar una tercera vía: me estoy preparando para tener Alzheimer.
Prevenir es bueno, y me he propuesto hacer todo lo que se puede hacer para evitar el Alzheimer.
Como de manera saludable, hago ejercicio cada día, mantengo mi mente activa,
eso es lo que las investigaciones dicen que deberíamos hacer.
Pero esas investigaciones también aseguran que no existe nada que pueda protegernos al 100%.
Si el monstruo va a por ti, te alcanzará.
Eso es lo que ocurrió con mi padre.
Mi padre era profesor bilingüe de Instituto. Sus aficiones eran el ajedrez, el bridge y escribir artículos de opinión.
(Risas)
Y aun así desarrolló demencia.
Si el monstruo va a por ti, te alcanzará.
Sobre todo si eres yo, pues el Alzheimer tiende a ser una enfermedad hereditaria.
Así que me estoy preparando para tener Alzheimer.
En base a lo que he aprendido cuidando a mi padre,
e investigando acerca de cómo es vivir con demencia, me estoy centrando en tres puntos para mi preparación:
Estoy cambiando las actividades que realizo por diversión, trabajando para mejorar mi fuerza física,
y, esta es la parte complicada: Estoy intentando convertirme en mejor persona.
Empecemos por los hobbies. Cuando tienes demencia, cada vez es más y más difícil divertirte.
No puedes sentarte y tener conversaciones con tus viejos amigos, porque no los reconoces.
Ver la televisión es confuso, y a menudo intimida y asusta.
Y leer se hace casi imposible.
Cuando cuidas a alguien con demencia, y te entrenan para ello,
te enseñan a hacerles participar en actividades familiares para ellos, prácticas e indefinidas.
En el caso de mi padre, el resultado fue dejarle rellenar informes.
Era profesor en una universidad pública; sabe qué aspecto tiene el papeleo burocrático.
Él firma con su nombre en cada renglón, marca todas las casillas,
escribe números donde cree que deberían escribirse.
Pero eso me hace pensar: ¿qué harían mis cuidadores conmigo?
Soy como mi padre. Leo, escribo, pienso mucho acerca de la salud global.
¿Me darían revistas académicas para que pudiese garabatear en los márgenes?
¿Me darían tablas y gráficos que pudiese colorear?
Por eso he estado intentando aprender a hacer cosas manuales y prácticas.
Siempre me ha gustado dibujar, así que lo hago más a menudo, aunque no sea muy buena.
Estoy aprendiendo a hacer origamis sencillos. Ya sé hacer una caja increíble.
(Risas)
Y estoy aprendiendo a tejer, de momento sé tejer una bola.
Pero, ¿saben? realmente no importa si soy buena. Lo que importa es que mis manos saben cómo hacerlo.
Porque cuantas más cosas me sean familiares, más recordarán mis manos,
más cosas podrán mantenerme ocupada y feliz haciéndolas cuando mi cerebro ya no dirija el timón.
Dicen que las personas que realizan muchas actividades son más felices,
que es más fácil cuidarlas y que esto incluso puede ralentizar el avance de la enfermedad.
Para mí, eso es ganar la partida.
Quiero ser todo lo feliz que pueda durante todo el tiempo que me sea posible.
Mucha gente desconoce el hecho de que el Alzheimer implica tanto síntomas físicos,
como síntomas cognitivos. Pierdes el sentido del equilibrio,
tus músculos tienen espasmos, y eso suele dejar a la gente cada vez menos y menos móvil.
Les asusta caminar. Les asusta incluso moverse.
Así que estoy realizando actividades que entrenen mi sentido del equilibrio.
Hago yoga y tai chi para mejorar mi equilibrio, para que cuando empiece a perderlo,
aún sea capaz de moverme.
Hago ejercicio con pesas, de modo que tenga la fuerza física para que,
cuando empiece a atrofiarme, disponga de más tiempo de movilidad.
Por último, el tercer paso, estoy intentando mejorar como persona.
Mi padre era amable y cariñoso antes de tener Alzheimer, y es amable y cariñoso ahora también.
He visto cómo perdía su inteligencia, su sentido del humor, sus habilidades lingüísticas,
pero también he visto esto: me quiere, adora a mis hijos,
quiere a mi hermano, a mi madre y a sus cuidadores.
Y ese amor hace que queramos estar cerca de él, incluso ahora,
a pesar de lo difícil que resulta.
Cuando lo despojas de todo lo que aprendió durante su vida,
su desnudo corazón aún brilla.
Nunca he sido tan amable como mi padre, y tampoco tan cariñosa.
Y lo que necesito ahora es aprender a ser así.
Necesito un corazón tan puro que, aun desprovisto de todo por la demencia, pueda sobrevivir.
No quiero tener Alzheimer.
Lo que quiero es una cura en los próximos 20 años, suficientemente pronto para que me proteja.
Pero si la enfermedad viene por mí, estaré preparada.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)